Timeline prompting in Sora 2 is
absolutely insane. Yet, nobody even know
what the hell timeline prompting is. We
first had Jason prompting. Now, all of
the sudden, we're switching to timeline
prompting. I understand it's kind of
crazy, but let me explain. Now, with
this new method of prompting, you can
keep consistent scenes easily across
your video that you generate in Sora 2.
And by using this exact method, I
created this video.
>> That's the ridge line. If we cut through
here, we can lose them. If they don't
burn the house first packs primed on
two.
Go back door.
>> Copy. Grid 493 over.
>> You heard that?
hanger's opening. I see it.
>> Basically, everything you've just seen
was generated using Sora 2 on Art List.
They were kind enough to sponsor this
video, so check them out in the
description down below. Now, with this
new method, you basically become a
director and you can decide everything
that's going on in your scene. Shout out
to Serio for breaking down this method.
Make sure to check him out in the
description down below. Okay, let me
start by explaining how you can do this
prompting technique. First, I want you
to go over to Sor 2. I'm using Art List
for this. So, there are two ways to
start using timeline prompting. The
first one is text to video and the
second one is image to video. Now with
image to video you have a bit more
control because you give it an image
input and with that image input the AI
can understand what style you're going
for, what character, what objects,
everything basically that you want to
know. Now with text to video, it's a bit
more a guessing game. So by then
describing what you exactly want to have
happen in that scene, the AI understands
that it needs to keep that character
consistent. it needs to change that
shot. And there's little to no guesswork
that needs to be done if you're using
the right prompt. So, I want you to
imagine this. I have this image here of
a knight looking at a map. Now, if I
were to give this a prompt, what most
people would do is they would prompt it
like this. A knight is looking at the
map. He puts it away and then he starts
marching forward on the battlefield. The
AI has little to no context. That's all
you gave it. So, with timeline
prompting, you're basically giving it a
lot more context by telling it exactly
what it needs to do at which moment. So,
let me break down one of these prompts
and show you what it looks like. So, now
you're looking at a timeline prompt. And
with this prompt, you add a lot more
detail to what you want to have happen
to your scene. But basically, it all
still comes down to what you have inside
of your head. And I will help you make
your own timeline prompt. No worries
about that. So, let me break it down.
First, we start off with the style. So
for this we're going with a gritty
medieval cinematic realism style. Then
we're talking about what we want to have
happen with the camera. So we're
starting off with a 50 mm to 85 mm prime
lens and we want to have a slow dolly
that is gently moving across the scene.
Now for the hook we are talking about
these time codes. So that's the first
three seconds. We're starting with a
tight profile close-up shot and then a
slow dolly as the wind is hissing and we
have it capturing the metal and chain
mail shimmer. Then moving on to the next
shot is context. The focus is going on
the parchment map and the camera is
tilting down as the fingers are like
tracing the route. Now then we have the
climax over the shoulder medium shot.
We're we're essentially directing this
like this is no more than just giving
more context about exactly what you want
to have happen. So, we're starting off
with the climax and then we switch over
to the resolution. Now, if you put this
into action, then you get a shot like
this. Okay, as you see, we start off
with a normal shot. We just see the
glistering. Then, we have him with his
fingers going over the map, over the
shoulder shot right here, and then he's
marching into the empty battlefield.
Honestly, quite insane just from an
image input. Now, that is essentially
what timeline prompting is. So you're
giving it all the context of what's
happening. JSON prompting similar format
bit more complicated but this could also
be done without using a chach. And
speaking of chat I've made a timeline
prompter for you. So you can just put in
your image or put in your idea and then
it will come up with the prompt because
that's the hardest part right you want
to describe what's happening on the
scene. But as you saw from my prompt
right here it's quite complicated. Like
there are so many words I can't even
pronounce. And with that like cha chip
tea will help you with that as long as
what you have in your mind comes out
good in the prompt. If you have an idea
what you want to create but you don't
have an image then you can just simply
switch over to the text to video
segment. And in here what I did is I
said I want to create a 12second video
of a real life VHS recorder that is
capturing a creepy scene of a guy
walking outside and meeting an alien. As
the tape glitches the alien is standing
right in front of him. Kind of like a
horror scene if you could say. So then
it gave me this prompt. So for the
style, we're do a horror style VHS
realism, eerie and analog aesthetic,
camera, static VHS recorder with
handheld shakiness, zoom glitches,
interlaced flicker, and some tracking
errors. The scene, it describes the
scene for me. Then we have what's
happening in the beginning. We have a
close-up of a VHS recorder. Let's say
you don't like this. You can just change
this manually. You can even ask the GPT
to change this for you. Then we're
switching over to a handheld view from
behind and then we're switching over to
a medium shot and then we're ending it
off with the video is heavily distorting
and all of the sudden there's an alien
in front of the camera. So I put this
into art list Sora 2 and with that I
wanted to also test out what's the
difference between Sora 2 and Sora 2
Pro. So I generated two videos for you
and this is the first one. This is the
standard Sora 2. So let's take a look.
I think it's quite good. If we take a
look at the prompt again, then we can
see we start off with a close-up of the
VHS recorder. If we break it down, start
off with a close-up. Then we have a
handheld view from behind. That is this
shot right here.
And then we have a medium shot. So we
have it right here switched to a medium
shot. After that we have the videos
distorting and the alien appears right
in front of the man. I do find that
right here like I didn't give an
instructions to switch to this front
view and then we have the alien like the
alien looks a bit weird here but I do
like the close-up in the end. So that is
generated with Sora 2. A lot cheaper to
use by the way. Now for Sor 2 Pro, which
is honestly the most expensive tool on
the market right now, but it is pretty
good. We got this result. So, let's take
a look.
Hello.
Oh god,
I might be glitching a little bit too
much. But honestly, if I were to
generate this again and again, I will
get completely different results. So,
that is the thing with AI. You still
have some control of the outcome, but
you cannot replicate exactly what you
want if you're doing these kind of like
complex prompts. Now, let me give you
another example, but this time we're
using image to video. So, image to
video, we're just switching over,
switching over to Sora 2. So, now we
just selected Sora to Pro. Then we have
16x9, 12 seconds, and 1080p. And I have
this image that I want to share. So,
this is this crazy looking dragon that I
made inside of Mid Journey. So, what I
can do is I can upload this also to the
Chetchup T. And now we just got to think
of what we want to have happen. So, I'm
just going to say the dragon roars takes
off and starts flying in the sky. He
gets shot down by a fireball and he
drops to the ground. Let's hope, by the
way, that Sora is not like censoring
this because that's the only downside of
Sora. Like, Sam, please, if you're
watching this, please just just allow us
to do a bit more uncensored stuff on
Sora. So, now I'm just going to copy
this prompt right here. And now we can
just put this inside of our prompter.
And then we click on animate. And let's
see what we get.
Now, if you want to try this out, I will
leave a link to my custom GPT and art
list in the description down below, so
you can have some fun with this timeline
prompting on Sora 2. If you want to
learn how to make better and cool
images, then check out the videos that's
on the screen right now and I will teach
you 10 different prompts of how you can
use Nano Banana.